the ambition is to reach the right  balance between security and privacy  with easier use of Health Data  first step for every researcher is to  find what data exists that can support  the research question  in that sense the European health data  space will provide access to a data  catalog from all data existing in Europe  in terms of Health Data it is  fundamental to ensure that Health Data  is available for the ones who need it  when they need it without compromising  the personal and sensitive nature of  Health Data my health at EU and health  h.eu save no effort to secure data to  make sure that you cannot extract the  personal identification of someone by  looking to the data this is a key  principle to ensure safe and secure  reuse of help data in a europe-wide  context  [Music]